[Music]
in cancer discrimination news mmm hey
when they do that submitted by Hendrick
go past noon that's really sickening
like a Jimi Hendrix all the Kendricks
Jim yeah oh is it because they're only
supporting some cancer researchers and
not other cancer researches researches
yeah is it because the researchers yeah
well some people I like I like this
cancer I like this one a lot it's good
she got this game what's the difference
melanoma will kill you
cuz its auditors know me you can cut it
out my mom so my dad my mom had that and
it got cut out
oh is that when you got your biopsy
thing and they're gonna take some more
out pretty soon I think they're coming
we went to Hawaii too much she can't be
in the Sun very long might come back yep
not a problem for me a cancer survivor
says he was kicked out of a restaurant
because his face was scaring customers
damn that's [ __ ] insane I mean the
house is crazy something let me see his
face about the meanest [ __ ] was a his
nose got cut off
yes yeah we were just talking to dr.
pimple popper on shout out the doctor
you were talking to her
yo she was on our podcast and I was like
what's your least favorite skin thing to
deal with and she's like well sometimes
people wait too long and they get skin
cancer on their nose and they have to
get their nose removed and that's number
of fun conversation good thing about
plastic surgery for the nose is pretty
common
oh yeah super easy I'm saying it's very
common now so psyched to get a
replacement for something prosthetic
like that it was a lot easier is what
I'm saying is it easy david easier i
said david saying it's Easy Street USA
get a new nose this is Kirby before this
is when he got skin cancer and this is
after whoa oh my God looks like a skull
show you love a more sensitive Joe he
was just factual it's like the
Cryptkeeper
I was thinking the Voldemort from Harry
Potter so it's all gone I'm both
you know there's no I and there's no the
nose looks like that in Harry Potter I
like his hat though Barry LaHood squat
so is that easy David huh I said it's
please I said it's easier than other
parts because like because prosthetic
nose things are a lot easier operation
for other things so I was giving him a
bright side I'm so glad he survived
you're a negative person thankfully he's
65 years old he's from South Carolina
and this his story went viral because he
said that he was kicked out of a diner
because his his injuries were scaring
customers I could still eat looking at
his face don't look at him then yeah
you've giving this interview and saying
that like the the manager owner like she
grabbed him from the arm she's like this
like he's describing it like this she
grabbed him from the arm like took him
to the office and told him listen either
you cover up your entire face when
you're here or you leave whoa why'd she
have to say it why did she treat him
like a [ __ ] animal that was his
version of it right but then it wasn't
the truth oh my heart hurts and so like
a lot of people were like you know it's
just a just like you guys just really
shocked like why would she treat this
man like it doesn't sound right and so
then they created a GoFundMe for Hansa
in order to get reconstruction the
daughter created one right now it's at
78,000 that'll cover it that's awesome
perhaps a seventy-five thousand full
that's great he has a nice bike - so the
diner started getting a ton I hate like
death threats and like everything and so
the diner
the store owner she ended up actually
showing surveillance footage of the
interact oh oh and this is what happened
come here for a minute I had a
conversation I wanted to talk with him
about why I never touched him you can
see that on camera I never touched him I
wanted to have a nice heart to heart
conversation with mr. Evans
there was no rudeness or whatsoever in
the conversation I asked him that maybe
the doctor had given him something like
an iPad or something that he could cover
the hole that's mean on his face
whenever he came to dine in at the forks
and if I could help him in any way how
nice
she's such a [ __ ] man but she's a nice
lady [ __ ] where she's like I'm a nice
lady no you dumb what is it good so she
wanted him another customer I've been in
business here for 25 years and I have a
lot of regular customers and mr. Evans
as my regular customer and I intended on
keeping him as a customer we had a nice
conversation you can see him agreeing
and laughing well he's embarrassed yeah
I know it comes back to work he lightly
shuts the door and a hands up going into
the aisle and I find some light some
food and then he leaves I didn't even
see any customers there complaining or
maybe it was like in the past I don't
know someone came up and who was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that said hey that
skeleton over there can you tell them
not to [ __ ] do that [ __ ] it's scaring
my kids like who's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that said that [ __ ] yeah you teach your
kids like not to stare enough to judge
yes yeah my kids start acting like a
little [ __ ] I would sit that [ __ ]
right in front of him and say eat
[ __ ] what made him say that she
grabbed him and drag him drag him into
the I guess that's how he felt about it
afterwards like but still they're still
illiterates alive he's still alive like
I don't agree with that part where he's
over here damaged she grabbed me by my
shirt and dragged me off because that's
the part that I think probably a lot of
people are outraged them yeah yeah so
why did he lie you know doing
that was a lie because maybe that
happened a different time that's true
she brings up a good point we don't know
that but just this manager she's saying
like in that instance when she talked to
him about this actually showed proof
like I never even touched him but yeah
he was just so I'm curious about like
why did he like them we don't know if
it's a live video but you guys can shut
this show so you guys can't create a
backstory that's not there know for sure
we're just like maybe who knows it's a
little odd like I'm only saying this
because we've done so many articles like
this where people have lied about [ __ ]
you know what I mean and they blow it up
like the guy that that wrote that yelp
review and he came to the restaurant and
then he looked and he left but it was
like he didn't even have that
interaction dejected so now I'm kind of
wondering like what was the why did that
happen there was a guy that was saying
that he was treated rudely at this
restaurant he was made to weigh this in
that but in the footage this guy shows
up he looks at the line and then he goes
[ __ ] and he leaves but he wrote a bad
yelp review like he was treated poorly
the wait was long this and that yeah I
mean obviously if it is if this was the
only interaction that he had with the
store owner then yeah he clearly
exaggerated this but then the daughter
said that her words hurt far worse than
whether she put her hands on him or not
so she admits that he lied that you
still fabricated a [ __ ] story and I
don't like that maybe he might have but
he might have believed it in his head
like that that's what how it happened
yeah what the [ __ ] that's lame
understandable like I don't like that
[ __ ] cuz then people react even more
angrier toward the lady and then there's
those consequences were like she's
getting death threats and all that
because they thought she was being
violent with the cancer guy and you know
if you look at her body language it was
very calm but she's explaining herself
was also saying like if I was yelling at
him or kicking him out of the store then
he would have you know you would think
that he would slam the door behind them
but no he liked that it really gently
and Haven walked down the aisle and
fought stuff yes because the body
language and how they were interacting
says otherwise
right so there was no yelling she didn't
grab him
so I mean the approach is very odd and I
guess like in her case as a business
owner me like I'm just trying to play
the other side right here because she
was saying that there were customers
complaining and that they would get up
and throw their plates in the track like
the food in the trash and then just walk
out saying it it [ __ ] the customers
those people are pieces of [ __ ] like all
of those people and you're like what the
[ __ ] you don't have an ego that's [ __ ]
up generally he was saying that he can't
put an eye patch over his eye because
like the skin around there is raw and so
like it'll rub up so he can't cover his
face and Plus how was he gonna eat with
his face covered Wow dude the customers
are pieces of shits they're the ones
that can best [ __ ] [ __ ] get [ __ ]
branded the case I wish for her as a
person she would have stood up for him
instead of those people and just like
hey you know he actually just went
through cancer and she is a returning
customer you probably know his backstory
because like he's a cancer survivor so
you know we're just just leave him alone
[ __ ] I can't my bacon and eggs look at
goddamn jack-o'-lantern I'd be more
scared like turning my bait Nick bacon
and eggs looking on a guy with a Jason
Voorhees mask on he not cover his face
up please Jesus you're like exactly yes
you saying that he would come in at
lunchtime and sit at the food booths
like right up to her busiest time every
day she's like I have bills to pay and I
work very hard to please customers she I
don't see absolutely anything wrong with
what I did it was like discrimination
right if he was black if he was this or
that or this or that it would all be
wrong every single one of them in her
like very ignorant post like she's like
well there's seven customers that are
perturbed by one person so seven
customer wins over one thing but the
problem is that you didn't equate is
that you've got treat this person like a
[ __ ] human being you know so she's
trying to see it like oh whoa how would
you treat it
I'd be like he's a cancer survivor
exactly and people go like oh I feel
like [ __ ] he's a returning customer he's
been coming here for years you know so
if it bothers you I'm sorry maybe you
guys could just look the other way
because I wouldn't if somebody comes to
my store over years and years and
they've been there a patron of my place
you're gonna get special treatment yeah
especially if you survive cancer yeah
you know nor I hate is when I go to
apply
many times and I don't get special
treatment I'm like I've been coming here
for [ __ ] forward they don't remember
your order and your order the same thing
every day exactly it's [ __ ] like that
run like why don't you give me that we
didn't get special treatment even when
we walked through Chipotle on our
wedding day the bride and groom gun and
then like a whole wedding party we went
through the entire line we stood in line
with everybody looks like what you want
for baby and they just hit me actually
cause a normal [ __ ] day nothing not
even like a 1% they tell you guys were
filming not that we want it we weren't
like doing it to get a discount but it
would you just be like hey whoa Congrats
yeah that's true it was yeah it was just
like hey what do you want brown rice or
white rice
[Music]
you